hello again friends I'm Alex lion you're
about to do lesson six of seven in this
mini course you're almost finished I'm
really happy for you if you haven't yet
subscribed to the channel now's the time
to do so make sure you visit the
homepage for the channel click on the
Subscribe button and you'll start
getting notifications for the course so
let's Jump Right
[Music]
In in our last lesson we looked at
pauses in this lesson six we'll look at
avoiding fillers
concise tip number six is to avoid
fillers call it a concise tip because
certainly avoiding fillers is going to
make you more concise it'll also add a
lot to your Clarity and to your
confident sound fillers drag out and
muddle messages for listeners and
fillers make you sound very unsure of
what you're saying here are some common
fillers WR sort of kind of something
like that as well as um uh you know so
and I know some people that count ums
and O during presentations but it's not
just annoying it also really goes to
your credibility there's some research
on powerless versus powerful speech and
when listeners and research situations
were showed videos of speakers who use
lots of fillers they thought they were
very unconfident or powerless in their
speech they give the same speakers a
clean script so they would not use any
fillers and the listeners in the
research situation thought wow they
really know what they're talking about
they're very confident so you can sound
confident just by getting rid of your
fillers it's a really important issue to
get after strategy one is to identify
your filler habits these are habits most
people have specific fillers that they
use over and over again I use kind of I
used to use that and I also use so and
I'm working on that one but I still use
it from time to time you want to listen
to yourself and pinpoint your specific
habits listen to a recorded presentation
for example or you might even ask a
trusted friend hey do I use any fillers
do I say you know or anything like that
and even if they don't have an answer
for you on the spot they'll be able to
listen to you as you move forward
strategy two is to replace fillers with
pauses talked about this in an earlier
lesson how awesome pauses can sound in
the right place some people call fillers
vocalized pauses in other words we
should be pausing but we're filling it
in with an utterance that doesn't need
to be there pauses give you time to
think but they also make you sound more
confident here we have an earlier
example with fillers put in there where
pauses should be and you'll notice how
tentative and how unsure it sounds so we
have a few items to cover today and uh
we'll look at our social media campaign
and uh we'll look at uh our overall
growth and uh Aon will take you know
suggestions about changes to the uh uh
website if I were to come to your
meeting and speak like this you would
notice instantly that I had lots of
fillers and I have seen people who were
supposed to be in leadership positions
doing this and listeners in fact did
mention wow they said um and ah a lot
this matters to people but what we want
to do is add pauses in those places
where we normally use fillers and we
would say the word pause or period in
our head like we mentioned in a previous
lesson pause is rest that clear
confident sound that we're going for and
you'll notice that there are some pauses
in the middle here but they still sound
better than the fillers so if we were to
look at this example ultimately our goal
would be to get rid of the fillers that
are in the middle of the sentences and
only use the pauses that punctuate our
communication in a desired
fashion we want to avoid fillers our
takeaway strategies are to identify your
specific filler habits
you don't do them all you just do some
and if you isolate your specific habits
you're going to have a much easier time
solving that problem and then replace
those fillers with actual
pauses step one is to practice saying
pause in your head instead of using
fillers up next we're going to work on
confident nonverbals that'll be our last
lesson and'll superimpose and thread
through all the other things we've
talked about in a really nice way